Oh folks how's everybody I hope you can
hear me well as you know I'm on the road
and I'm on vacation so I took my
computer with me but my computer has low
sound I can't do much about it
I've got enhancements over that my home
my usual home and I don't have it here
so I hope you can hear me so if you
can't hear me please let me know but
again I can't do much about it all I can
do is ask you to turn your speaker's on
or whatever okay so let me say the
following we have a discussion this week
at the rational scientific method group
in which is on Facebook so if you don't
know about it you may want to join and
participate in such discussions with a
few of these intelligent people and we
had a discussion about the word object
what is a woman what is an object what
is a thing okay and once again let me
see if I can ask someone if you can hear
me well I hope my son's coming out okay
anybody can answer with I really would
appreciate it give you a minute to
respond there can everybody hear me okay
no nobody can hear me okay echoing I
don't know what to do about it
I could be could be the room I'm in it
could be the room because it's a it's a
big room but I don't know should I speak
louder or should I speak okay okay thank
you
I'll try to speak slower anyways we had
a discussion about the word object okay
and one of the issues that comes up is
why do we need to talk about objects in
physics is that an a key word is that an
important word and all I can do is put
up what I but I called the golden
principle of physics
that's how I'll start today it goes up
like this physics requires an object you
can't do physics without an object okay
so that's the starting point and some
people say we'll hold it
aren't there concepts also in physics
don't don't use concepts I mean like
distance or position we use energy at
least some people do math etc don't be
used concepts as well and the answer the
answer is that you need to know the
context you don't need to understand the
context here's the context okay what do
we mean when we say that physics
requires an object it means specifically
this it means that you cannot move a
concept you can only move an object okay
that's the issue the issue is that it
envisage we cannot move concepts we
cannot say that we're going to move love
or or even location or any concept you
can't say you moved a field that you
transfer an energy that you move the
mass that's the issue the issue you
cannot
move a concept okay you might say well
everybody knows that right
I mean it's self-explanatory or most
people at least would think it's
self-explanatory and maybe not I mean
I'll give you some examples here why
it's not self-explanatory why we've been
doing exactly the opposite we've been
moving concepts at least for the last
100 years here's one example okay and
this is a how they discovered the black
the first black hole Cygnus x1 now this
is this is an illustration okay this is
not the real thing but what you see here
is that you've got a star which is the
visible thing there that's flirting
that's horny and it's orbiting around
nothing seemingly around nothing okay
and so that's how they came up and he
said well look what's at the center of
that orbit is a black hole and what is a
black hole well black hole is all mass
and no body well that sounds pretty much
like a concept to me in fact let me
illustrate it my way here's my way okay
illustrating that okay we have mass and
we have something in this case a turtle
going around mass okay so what is mass I
mean that's what black hole is all mass
and no volume this is this is a perfect
illustration of that notion of that
theory and the question is by what
mechanism does the mass attract or
compel the turtle to go around here's a
better illustration of that
that's what mass is mass is kilograms
that's all it is you know that's how we
measure mass mass is a mathematical
concept and for someone to say look we
have mass we have kilograms somewhere in
a region of space and this compels a
star to move around the kilograms well
you have not explained to kilograms you
have not
the mechanism okay you have not
explained you know what is the mechanism
by what means does the kilogram some
mathematical concept compel you know a
turtle to move around or a star and
here's another version of something
similar to that also related to gravity
this is a bird flying on earth okay
we've seen this many times you have this
experience
what would this bird do on the moon well
fall flat on his face
that's what it would do and you say well
yeah of course and what's the reason for
that well you say well there's no air
but then you're missing the point
see the point is the bird fell down okay
fell towards the center of the planet in
this case boom right the satellite but
the correct interpretations at Yi air on
earth was hoping it up against something
that was already pulling it down and so
what you gotta identify is that
something and the question is you can't
put a concept in there like I've been
discussing the last couple weeks
a lot of the dissidents who object to
general relativity what they do is they
say particles but I'm not sure you can
explain this with particles because
again one of the problems you've got is
this situation where you got particles
coming from every part of the universe
supposedly these are ether of particles
or whatever particles this these
theorists imagine and the question is
why would the particles push down on a
person here on earth with a higher
acceleration compared to an astronaut in
this case right which is farther away
from the earth in other words that guy
has no gravity pulling on it or barely
any gravity pulling on it
from the earth whereas the person that
Satan astronaut on the surface of the
earth would be pulled down at 9.8 meters
per second squared we know this and so
the question is if you're going to
explain this with particles pushing down
on the astronaut you know you're gonna
have a little bit of trouble explaining
this difference okay you're gonna have
to really go out of your way aside from
the fact that particles cannot explain
other phenomena such as magnetism and
light and the workings of the atom as I
discussed this in the past couple of
weeks the question is you put a concept
in there and if you if you don't put an
object in there you're essentially doing
gravity with with spirits you know
that's essentially what you're doing if
you put some kind of octave you don't
make the object visible what you're
really doing is displeased spirits in
there you know I see concepts spirits
and you say well what's what's the
spirit you know we always talked about
spirits in traditional religions well
here let's define the word spirit spirit
is a concept uses an object that's what
spirit is okay
we have synonyms such as energy soul
field consciousness way any person using
those words is introducing spirits okay
introducing concepts as objects this
one's the specific google is walking
down the stairs is this concept okay
this is the problem the problem is that
you cannot continue doing gravity with
concepts you must put an object now
particles are object real particles
right but again you have that problem
wearing you know how do you explain the
difference between the acceleration of
gravity here on the surface of the earth
and the acceleration out there in space
near the earth for example the
satellites they go around the earth
okay so yeah we need to define the word
object because it's crucial to the
discipline and it starts out with the
what I call golden principle you need to
establish some kind of cornerstone and
that cornerstone is that you can't do
physics without objects
you can't move concepts around that's
the point I make okay well we're gonna
be to define the word object thing
entity medium whatever you wanna call it
substance we should have done a great
job after ten thousand years we should
have that definition down pat you know
it should be perfect and sweat the
contrary here here's our Wikipedia
definition of the word object you'll see
it and you can see that if they have
several definitions with which by the
way a lot of people use simultaneously
or jump from one to the other without
even knowing ok so here you have a
philosophy a thing B or concept so
according to the philosophers a thing is
a concept so they don't see any
difference between a concept and a thing
and then they put a bead which is live
object so they have all these different
categories you'd love them all in one
boat and they say ok I'll sell it as a
package entities something already we
have a problem we have the word
something in there which is the word
we're trying to define but it says
something that is tangible and within
the grasp of the senses what senses I
mean what happens with an object that's
on the other side of the universe a star
it's not tangible I can't see it I can't
smell it can't taste it
can't hear it what scent is there
another sense I mean I don't know you
told me now I now do not necessarily
you know within the grasp of the census
and if you do that what you're doing is
introducing a second object you so you
need two objects to define the word
object you need an interface you need
touch you need see you need tasting it
smell
there's gotta be you know the moon is
not an object until the asteroid hits it
which means you also have to run a an
experiment a test object a speck an
object which does not exist at any time
or place okay so they have objects and
abstract objects whatever that is
another category so they have all these
little categories each one for a
specific purpose
it sounds very ad hoc to me and then you
have this logic and the after I got busy
walking abstract and physical are
opposite are evident right so here we
have the physical logic what is that an
identifiable collection of manner well a
collection of matter already is many
objects so they're seeing a collection
of many objects that's what a physical
object is and so it's a circular
definition means you haven't defined
what an object is you just seen it's a
bunch of objects that's all that he said
there what does matter is any substance
so matters supped is a substance right
okay that has mass and takes up space by
having body okay so we have we have all
these circular definitions they're all
synonyms they're using synonyms that you
find cinnamon because they're never
defined the word and the last one is is
the worst one of all where people
confuse the word of object with the
subject of a sense that which we can
talk about okay and so what happens you
know people say well you know I can talk
about motion and talk about an orbit the
orbit of Jupiter does that make orbit a
physical object just because it's a noun
- because it's the subject of the
sentence
so all these notions that these people
have introduced over the years
specifically the philosophers you know
they go through all this analysis and
the other of it they said you know we
don't really know what an object is
that's where we are today and you say
bill yer you're trying to sell me on a
whopper there well no I'm not look here
it goes
this is the Stanford encyclopedia of
philosophy on the word object you can
look it up yourself I'm just gonna give
you here the rundown and that's what it
looks like okay this is what they have
on their on their site these are just
the headings each one of these is
analyzed separately and if you read it
well you got going psychiatrist after
that if you read all that and understood
it you know just look at some of the
titles here and you'll see what they've
analyzed over the years and the worst
part is when you reach the end you still
don't know what an object is and no one
in anywhere in philosophy on planet
Earth knows what an object is they keep
debating this stuff over and over and
going over the same issues over and over
here let me give you an example I just
pulled out of this a few lines for you
to see where we where the philosophers
stand on the word object this is again
from the Stanford encyclopedia of
philosophy okay this is what it looks
like okay and I'll just read a couple
here that says here we have objects are
in space and time properties are not
that's one of the statements that you'll
see in there
artistes are sense perceptible against
they want to introduce
senses okay and you know for those of
you who've heard of my proposal my
hypothesis hypothesis which is the
single thread okay here's the single
thread how do you get to it how do you
how do you identify the single thread
you identify it with a touch smell taste
hear or see or any of the senses no you
we even approaches it through the mind
we know he cannot touch light we don't
like you know not only you cannot touch
it but you cannot see it you cannot see
a mediator of light okay and for sure
nobody asked whether you can smell or
taste it but that's a value question as
well I mean you know can you hear the
light you know light itself become the
mediator of light and though the issue
is the only way to approach you know
invisible entities that mother nature
uses is uh is through three of mine you
gotta think about it you gotta imagine
you gotta visualize okay
here's a couple more from the stanford
encyclopedia says in ordinary language
we are inclined to call only material
objects objects and that's the only one
they got right people confuse the
notions that we have of ordinary speech
of our ordinary world and those are
objects so if you know the tables are
not in the chairs on empty and we get so
used to that that when you try to define
it very specifically for the purposes of
physics people immediately you know jump
up and say no no that's not an object
because of this this and that and then
go back to the ordinary speech notions
our ordinary everyday notions of what an
object is that's not what an object is
for the purposes of science or physics
okay
in physics you have to define it
precisely because you're gonna be giving
a dissertation tell someone your theory
about whatever you better know exactly
what an object is you can't no longer
bring the notion of ordinary speech of
of our ordinary life and say well you
know what an object is now I know please
tell me because no one has ever defined
this word throughout history if the word
object is a cornerstone even if it's
necessary to do physics it is surprising
that no one in the last ten thousand
years has written a book of physics a
textbook of
whether they start up by saying oh this
is what an outfit is there's not a
single textbook of physical teach my
workers there's not a single textbook of
physics that begins by telling you what
an object is and if you do need objects
to do physics well it's a big omission I
would say you know it's like you're
missing the ABCs of that book or
whatever you wrote one way to explain
the thing is to mark out what it does
no that's first we don't explain nothing
we don't explain the table we point to
it say table and sound now what someone
knows what I'm referring to when I say
10 evil and then no don't we don't
define it by first we don't define
objects and second we don't define them
by their usage we don't say a table is
that where you couldn't play Don or
Terry's what you sit on you don't define
words we have to point a name what we're
referring to so that the et yes for
terrestrial knows our language
understand some things understands what
we are referring to okay
I think essence of nature can take a
variety of forms the real definition of
X might be put to be X is to be Y or the
real definition of a category F to be F
is to be G what in the world does that
have to do with the word object they go
to movies this nonsense about identity
and a equals a or a is equal to B what
is all this not what's that got to do
what they find the word object and this
is what you'll find on their side
according to the bundle vewy objects are
bundle of properties that's what it on T
is a bundle of properties what sense
does that make
can we use this in physics their
particular
their particularism maintains that
objects have their properties as can
constraint constituents there are
subjects of properties again subject
instead of you know thinking of what
you're going to talk about right or the
items to which the properties are
pass by instance instantiation they have
all these notions that they develop the
over thought this this thing way over
thunk it and you come up with all these
arguments and theories and all I want is
a definition what is an object please
and you know you don't take all this
time to define the word object I just
need a definition I need to know what
I'm to use for the purpose of bizzy's
and it goes with all these theories of
all these opinions of what an object is
to this guy that guy who cares I give an
option
I need a definition are you using
physics and you won't get from the so
called physicists really mathematical
physicists why because they don't do
qualitative stuff they let the
philosophers define the works for them
ok so if you were to know what an object
is in mathematical physics you don't go
to the matter of mathematical physics
department you go across campus to the
philosophy department and let them
define it for you and tell you what an
object is and this is the stuff you'll
see you see the problem is it's a little
bit of a problem because you got one
discipline that has nothing to do with
busy defining the words for physics and
we confront the mathematical physics
here you have a mathematical physicist
who's got a PhD you studied 10 years of
the universe he's an expert right he
knows about the moon space-time
everything right and you asked him the
question what is an object and he goes
in there and he said let me look it up
and he goes through the dictionary or
the encyclopedia huh what do you think
you gotta look it up what happened you
missed you skipped Skinner kindergarten
I mean this is stuff that she should
have had you know in your first class
what is it object and the guy has to
look at me you know and what they do is
they regurgitate they just transcribe
what they read they say oh this was a
weakness
Sanford says that's what they do and you
can see by the other definitions there
that you know they're all the same it's
it's all it's all a lot of analysis and
you can look at the article for yourself
right you just look up the word object
for Stanford encyclopedia and you'll see
where the Philosopher's are today it's a
good synthesis of what all the
philosophers on earth are thinking when
they talk about the word of action and
they're the ones who define it for
physicists and this is what you'll see
you'll see all this nonsense you will
not know what an object is okay so yeah
we we don't have a definition of the
word object and that's the first problem
because we have we absolutely need to
define the word object for the purposes
of physics because we can't do physics
without an object why because we can't
move anything which is not an object we
can't move concepts around can't move
spirits okay and you might say well has
someone in the history of humanity
defined the word object specially the
way I do I'm gonna find it and here you
have a rundown this is just the
synthesis of maybe among the most
important philosophers and physicists
so-called physicists who tackled the
issue throughout time okay in different
eras okay everyone from Confucius always
Simone de Beauvoir and these people know
I mean and you'll say well look so so
Aristotle mentioned something about form
Euclid mentioned something about form
they never none of these people none of
them ever came up with the golden
principle you need an object in physics
to do physics and even if they were not
visited businesses they should have
zeroed in on that principle you need to
really think that you need an object to
do physics and you need an object to do
physics you need to define it concisely
and not LeBron
about arguments saying well let me tell
you this I'm gonna tell you they have my
opinion and no you gotta just give me a
definition none of these people did that
okay
none of them so we one of these is your
hero well I I'm sorry to tell you about
trash so you'll hate me for it and I'm
one of the most hated guys so don't
worry about it so just just quick
synthesis objects is not equal to exists
object is not that which is used for
this or that we don't define the word
object by its usage okay and an object
is not a collection of which is known as
neurology okay in other words uh we
don't look at what comprises an object
because if you look at what makes up an
object you're already invoking two three
four millions of objects so so you
haven't defined it you can't say enough
Jesus which is made out of objects
that's what you're saying essentially so
no not Jesus not a collection of
whatever okay so what are they what an
object is not well here we have some of
you've seen this in the past this is
what an object is not it's not what we
can see it's not what we can touch it's
not that which has mass that we test
volume it's not that which moves or can
move not made of parts again neurology
that's something you visualize sometimes
it's known as temporal parts a theory of
object has come up sometime in the past
where you don't see the table that one
go you know when you enter the room it's
like you see it piece by piece in
microseconds so you see the front of the
table first and then as you go along you
see the rest of the table or if that's
too small for you you look at the room
yeah you'll see the whole room in one
shot you can see it from one side of the
room too
the other that's the notion they have
okay temporal parts instead of that
which we can use in sentence it's not
the subject of a sentence not not in
physics you can't use the word orbit as
a physical object you know people talk
about the orbit of mercury or whatever
you can't use the word orbit as a
physical object so just because you use
it as a noun
just because it's a noun in ordinary
speech just because you can be used as a
subject of a sentence it doesn't
automatically translate into an object
it's not that which exists exists an
update are two seven things and I'm
gonna be covering that next time it is
that's a another big monster it's not
that which is 3d we have objects that
are two years I'm gonna show you in a
minute and it has to be standalone in
other words he can't be a dependent
object in other words you've heard of a
magnetic field a lot of people think
magnetic field is a physical object and
the main thing recently think it's the
treatises now if you are having the back
of their minds that it's an antique is
because it does things it can you know
this so-called field ism spirit right
attracts another magnet attracts iron
filings so it has that influence that
physical influence and people say oh
it's something and what what is
something both something's are key it's
a thing that's that's the logic and and
the problem with the word field is that
you know it's not a standalone on you
can't have a field on magnetic field
without the magnet you know I can't
bring a magnetic field and put in the
center of the conference room for you to
see it from every science yeah I see
what a field is now you can't do that
what a field it's like yeah I always
give the analogy with the Angels halo
you know without the angel the halo is
just a ring or a plate deeper than a
witch yeah if you want to talk about
halo you
angel the angel gives it that holiness
and the same thing with a magnetic field
the magnetic field is not a standalone
object
it's a dependent object a true object
has to be standalone okay if it's the
only object in the universe that's the
only one God made and then he
disappeared right it should stand alone
should stand alone it should be and you
have to conceive of it as made of a
single piece you can't say oh s--- made
out of all these little parts and atoms
and no it's made of a single piece
because a table when you point to it
you're not thinking of the millions of
gazillions of atoms that comprise a
table that's not one of people is a
table is not one gazillion atoms
that's not my table is that's a
neurology all you said is it's made out
of atoms but it's made up no when you
point it's a table you're referring to
the whole shabang as if it were made of
a single piece okay okay let's move on
here I'm gonna get to the real good
stuff here's my definition very very
difficult one and object is that which
has shape hey why shape shape is the
only Universal property of all objects
all objects have seen some objects can
be seen some of these can be touched
some of you can smell not see you know
there there's uh you've got gases that
you can smell but you cannot see
phosphine phosphine you can't smell
either I can't think of one right now
but there are gases that you cannot see
you can smell and let alone here in
other senses right but yeah and an
object is that we just shape very simple
now we're not me we can we don't have to
you don't have to think about
all those different methane okay thank
you yeah the point is that you know you
have you you don't you don't identify an
object with your senses because if you
do you're already introducing you're
already introducing a another object you
need to have an interface that you need
to have a test you're saying essentially
if I don't see it it's not an object
until I see it so the table is not an
object until I see it and that creates
problem for the blind man because you
can't see the moon and so the up the
moon is not an object for him because
you can't see anything so we have a
problem with that type of definition
okay so what's the problem
well some people always raise this issue
and they say okay I got you bill okay
you destroyed all my proposals you said
it's not a volume it's not math it's not
see touch okay so tell me what is shape
this is where they want to get you said
so it is shape
why don't you define shape okay and I've
been at it for 20 years
believe me so I've collected a few
arguments and I'm just gonna synthesize
them for you today okay and then I'll
turn on the the questions I'll go with
the questions but let me just give you a
synthesis of the arguments okay let me
give you a synthesis of the arguments of
why we don't define the word shape so
let's pay attention here so we don't
repeat ourselves right it turns out we
require a precise definition of any of
the other criteria we didn't ask you
what did you mean by mass what did you
mean by volume what you mean by by see
but if you mean by touch what did you
mean by motion no no all we need to know
is the difference in criteria you know
are you gonna use C or are you
touch our use volume I'm going to use
motion that's what we need to understand
that the the ordinary meanings of those
were suffice to compare them and find a
criterion that we're going to use to
define the word object for the purposes
of physics that's what we're that's what
we're trying to do here we're trying to
find the word object for the purposes of
physics we want to be able to use it
consistently in a dissertation and so if
you're gonna use C touch motion etcetera
and you need another object that's no
good for physics because your your first
requiring a second object and then
you're putting a test you're saying I
need to see it move and if it doesn't
move it's not an object and I need to I
need to see it and if I can't see it
it's not an object if I can't taste it
here so it becomes subjective so no you
know you don't need to know what all
these words mean precisely all you need
to know is which criteria you're gonna
use to define the word object okay then
the other one is the devil's advocate
wishes to show that no word can be
defined precisely scientifically you
can't use it consistently that's what
they're saying that's what the person is
aiming at my saying buddy can't define
any where thought you're doing your
semantics that's that's the goal because
you lost the battle he said well it's
not body buts not mass I'm gonna make
sure that it's not shape either and the
way I'm gonna get there is by saying
that you can't define shape and so the
problem is that you know the third
runner why teach the devil's advocate
asked you to define back which or has
you know are these an easier can you
define can any of you define the word
the article any better than shape or
which or has that has is a big problem
also because
in ordinary speech we say oh I have but
see you can have a headache and you can
have 10 cents in in your pocket and to
have one to have the other don't have
the same physical meaning you know I
have love is that the same thing as
having you know a pair of pants and so
you gonna go through all this analysis
to find out that the word have is gonna
be very tricky okay you got to go
through this whole process then by
kicking into the devil's advocates the
man you just go in and the sphere
duration okay yeah he's just gonna keep
asking you won't be fighting this define
a you find me you find Z you want you to
define word after word after word he's
just gonna keep you all busy all day no
no the buck stops here the buck stops
here you mean you find based on a
criterion we choose one of my kids we're
done you don't have to keep going so
what would you be my shady b-bye-bye the
word that you use that you find shape
and someone down the line no the buck
stops there you got to stop at some
point because at that point this becomes
extreme Devils advocacy and there's no
real purpose to that endless iteration
other than to show that oh you can't be
find any work scientific so we don't
start you know we don't do any visit
because we can't define the word object
is that is that what we're supposed to
do okay and then we do not need to
define shape we merely need to
distinguish between criteria okay that's
fine and for those who still want to
know what shape is well you do it on
your own okay and here it is here's a
test that you can run to prove shape to
yourself the definition of shape it's go
to kindergarten you know and show the
toddlers a ball and a cube you know some
kind of take one of excuse and take a
ball and hopefully they have a seat
color the same materials same everything
and just ask the little kid
what's the difference between these two
objects and it's a shape and so he'll
teach you if you missed kindergarten
he'll teach you what shape is okay we
don't need a super awesome or
unimaginable definition of the word
shape we just need to know a shape is
different than motion if it's different
than see touch volume mass subject we
just need to find that there's a
difference you know between these words
if you can tell the different repeat
shape and motion you can you got a mate
if you know the difference between those
two words you're okay okay and so I'm
just gonna finish off by saying that
these are the foundations of physics
I'll be touching in the next
presentation maybe in the next couple of
lectures I don't know if we'll get to
all of them and specifically I want you
to know that first one something nothing
you know what is an object something and
that word right at the bottom exist okay
exist is the other important word of
physics physics is the science of
existence physics tries to understand
and explain what exists okay
and so yeah that's that's the subject
matter of physics you need to know or
try to understand try to explain when
you give it a dissertation you trying to
explain something something to someone
you try to stay at your theory
specifically a mechanism right any an
object you've absolutely needed objects
and that's what exists objectively and
then of course you know you're only want
to talk about things that exist physics
does not deal with squares and ideal
queue
Superman snow white all those things
that the Greeks you know used as the
foundations for geometry all those
figures you know physics doesn't deal
with that physics deals with real
objects out there and the only ones we
have to figure out today are the
invisible mediators how does mother
nature do her stuff and she doesn't do
it with concepts she doesn't do it with
spirits
she does it with objects that we can't
see or touch or smell or taste or here
so you won't be able to go to the lab
and prove through an experiment what
that object is you're gonna have to grab
a PT or sit back do some armchair
physics right and think and try to
visualize how she could be doing her
little magic gravity invisible magic
right gravity magnetism light
electricity the workings of the atom and
out there in space how does she do these
things where star goes seemingly around
nothing dark matter why I have galaxy
rotates and the stars on the outer edge
not only travel faster or than the ones
on the inside but don't fly away all
those invisible mechanisms is what we
need to explain and the only way we're
gonna explain them is by trying to
visualize what physical object mother
nature's using as mediators what secret
agents she uses okay turn on the
questions let's see if I have any
otherwise I'll see you next week let's
see we got here um physical outline okay
I got no uh
no questions you got two seconds and
otherwise I'll see you probably next
week remember I'm on vacation and uh
when I get home I'll return to my
regular
lectures okay well if you do have
questions please raise them a patreon
you don't have to pay anything you just
have to be you just have to sign up okay
so put them in the patreon page and if
you do put them here well I won't answer
them in YouTube what I'll probably do is
if if the question is good I'll address
it in the next lecture we'll see you
that bye bye